(dance music)
- [Boy in Black] I love
chicken nuggets at McDonald's,
so I'm really excited for this.
I like it.
- Mmm. It's so good.
- Chicken nuggets on a stick.
- I love chicken wings, I love McNuggets.
This is the baby.
- To me, Chicken McNuggets
taste artificial,
it's kind of like fake meat.
This is real meat.
- This needs to exist in America.
I do like the exoticism of it.
- And then, you pour
it all over your fries.
- I dig it.
- Oh, my gosh. This is mine.
- It kind of reminds me of
a Trader Joe's dry seaweed.
- I would like this if the seaweed was
in liquid form like ketchup.
- [Girl in Purple] And then you shake it..
- You know those Asian instant
noodles that you crush up
and you add the powder in it?
That tastes exactly like that.
- MSG.
- Nacho taste to it.
- I feel like with this,
you have to wipe your hands
all the time.
- [Girl in White] It looks like fish
but I think it's chicken.
Hold on.
- Mmm.
- This is fried and crispy
patty and it has pork belly
and it tastes like bacon.
- What is this?
- I think there's too much mayo.
It takes away the taste of the meat.
- It has like mashed
potatoes or something.
- This isn't better than bacon.
- (cries)
- It's just really tender.
It's just really good.
- No, no, no, no, no.
This is bad. This is not good at all.
Don't bring this to the US.
- [Girl in Purple] So this is
a chicken pineapple ciabatta
and it has cheese and tomato.
- It looks pretty good.
- This is really good.
- Mmm.
- Wow. It tastes very Asian. (laughs)
- It tastes like soy sauce.
- This isn't as hard as American ciabatta.
- This tastes really healthy.
- So, it tastes like a Vietnamese sandwich
with Chinese barbecue pork.
- I would eat this.
- I think this is a A+.
Because this is from McDonald's,
you would think that
it's a bit watered down,
but it tastes really authentic.
- Oh, my friggin' goodness.
- It's really good.
- Tastes so creamy, like condensed milk.
- It's really foamy.
- Dang, it tastes like stuff
out of an actual boba shop.
- It's not diluted or watered down.
- If I were to freeze this, this would be
like a green tea ice cream.
- Wow. I would drink this for breakfast.
- I think all the flavors
fit in Asia because
it's like more Asian sensibilities
like with the seaweed and the crab.
I think it'd be interesting
to have it like maybe
once a year in the US.
I think that'd be cool.
I dig the McWings.
Bring that to the US.
It's so good.